i want to win all of them let's be very
clear about that it only took
12 years for john legend to earn the
egot
that's the emmy grammy oscar and tony
well winning the egot would mean a lot
here's how the best selling artist
worked his way into this exclusive
winner's circle
we will make room we have a plenty of
room at the house we'll make room for
all the trophies
[Music]
in 2005 john legend's debut studio album
get lifted was a smash success the album
earned him eight grammy nominations
and the following year legends egot
journey began
when he took home three awards including
best new artist
well nobody's a newcomer anybody who
wins best new artist
is only new to the general public they
always work
you know a lot beforehand to get to to
get a record deal to
get the album out that's a long struggle
people sometimes criticize people that
come off as cocky or whatever but every
artist
that makes it this far has to be very
confident because you have to believe
that
you have something special to offer the
world and
i believe that it took a minute for the
rest of john's egot journey to get going
though
nine years exactly in 2015
things got put on the fast track it's
been an incredible year ever since i got
married things have just gotten better
in my life so uh
she makes things happen we're gonna
change the whole prenup
doc this is it
sound is the place common was already
working on the historical drama selma
when he reached out to one of his oldest
friends and collaborators
together they wrote and performed the
film's title song
glory
[Music]
in 2015 they won the academy award for
best original song
he described what they were looking for
and he gave me some ideas for the title
for the song
and one of the ideas he gave me was
glory and
that word really inspired me one day
when the glory comes it will be
my thoughts were that the song should
sound triumphant but also
realize that there's more work to do so
when i said one day when the glory comes
that means we still have
more work to do with half of his egot
complete john legend headed to the great
white way
well we're proud of the play we were
able to produce
august wilson's jitney for broadway and
it was the
last august wilson play that had yet to
be shown on broadway
and for it to get recognized with six
nominations it's really amazing
and uh we're hoping it does well to
tony's not too shabby for his first
invitation
in 2017 legend won a tony award for best
revival of a play
no miracles needed here because just one
year later
legends egot was complete in 2018
he won an emmy award for producing jesus
christ superstar
live in concert and legend also played
the titular role for the nbc production
of the beloved musical
if you know why i do i don't care why
you do it
it's kind of surreal it's something i
never even thought about like you know
when i started my career
i probably wanted to win some grammys
and sell a lot of records and
all that started happening pretty
quickly but i never dreamed that i would
be here
winning an emmy and being in that rare
group of people that have won all four
of these major academy awards
uh is such a huge honor and i'm just
happy i was part of such a great show
and later that night john legend's wife
chrissy teigen showed
everyone where he's going to keep all
those egot trophies
perfect it was an extraordinary
achievement
for one of the greatest artists working
today but when e.t caught up with
legends soon after
he opened up about the things that are
truly important to him
i love being a father i love being a
husband i love being a musician and
getting to do what i love to do every
day
which is write and perform songs and
and hopefully make people's lives a
little better by the music and the art
that we create
you